the FDA and the CDC now see an early
signal of a possible link between the
Pfizer covid vaccine and an increased
risk of stroke and I for one think it is
terribly irresponsible of those
government agencies to spread what I
have been reliably informed for the past
three years is a baseless and dangerous
right-wing conspiracy theory now before
I am taken off YouTube less than one
minute into my show I want to be clear
that that possible risk is not merely
being reported on social media it's not
even just being reported by news
agencies such as Reuters see right there
there it is U.S FDA CDCC early signals
possible Pfizer bivalent covid shot link
destruct by the way
the original headline didn't even
include the word possible the original
headline just said FDA CDCC an early
signal of Pfizer coveted shot link to
stroke
and then they had to edit it they said
this story has been refiled with an
edited headline to clarify that the link
to a stroke is possible not definite but
you know it's it's there man it's there
and why is it there how do we know it's
there because the report is coming
straight from the agencies themselves
here it is right on the fda's website
which for me raises only one question
if the endemically dishonest FDA and CDC
are finally admitting what many of us
suggested and were castigated for
suggesting from the beginning of the
vaccine rollout
can you even imagine how bad the risk
situation actually is a Michael Knowles
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from Jeremiah was a
bullfrog
who says the professor showing the
students gay porn sounds like he's
pushing conversion therapy that's true
that's actually a very good point that
Penn State Professor who told all his
straight students to watch gay porn so
they could feel more gay that is a kind
of conversion therapy but in our culture
the conversion is only allowed to go in
one way you're never allowed to convert
toward the side of conservatism or
tradition or truth justice and beauty or
any of those no no it's just whatever
the libs want to do today that's that's
the only thing you're allowed to convert
to everything else is going to be
illegal okay the lives are really coming
after us and when situations get dicey
all right when maybe the power starts to
go out you're going to want to check out
four Patriots right now head on over to
four the number four patriots.com use
code Knowles a tree branch hit a power
line in Ohio in 2003. it shut down 21
power plants around 100 people died we
have a power grid that was designed in
the a 1800s even the White House sees
that they're saying that two-thirds of
the grid is at least 25 years old so
they recently announced billions of
dollars to update it how long is that
going to take that is why having your
own solar power is more important than
ever with the four Patriots Patriot
power generator you get a portable solar
generator that does not install into
your house you can take it with you
wherever you go the four Patriots
Patriot power generator is powerful
enough for your phones medical devices
even your fridge right now you can go to
fourpatriots.com use code Knowles kwles
to get 10 off your first purchase on
anything in the store you'll also get
their famous guarantee for an entire
year after your order plus free shipping
on orders over ninety seven dollars a
portion of every sale is donated to
Charities that support our veterans and
their families go to fourpatriots.com
use code noltz kwles to get 10 off that
is four patriots.com use code Knowles
kwles to get yours today a I
I don't want to have to say I told you
so
in this case though I not only will say
I told you so but I'm going to have to
take responsibility for telling you the
opposite of what is so because My
Doppelganger Rachel Maddow on MSNBC
typified the liberal establishment for
the last three years in what she had to
say about the covid vaccine
now we know that the vaccines work well
enough that the virus stops with every
vaccinated person
remember that you remember the virus
stops remember Dr fauci Rachelle
wolensky Joe Biden if you get the shot
sorry if you get the shot you are not
going to get the virus you remember that
you remember the remember when they told
you the shots were completely safe if
you raised any questions about it
whatsoever you were not only wrong and
stupid and uneducated but you actually
were a murderer because you were you
were convincing people not to go get the
vaccine that it would have absolutely no
deleterious health effects whatsoever
and and you're you're preventing them
from stopping the spread because don't
forget you get the shot that totally
stops the spread doesn't matter that
none of that was true
doesn't matter that nothing they told us
about the vaccines or covid for that
matter was true
that's what you had to believe until now
three years later they're willing to
admit in the face of a ton of evidence
yeah okay maybe maybe there's a link
between the shots and stroke maybe yeah
maybe there's a link between the shots
and heart problems yeah maybe there's a
link between the shots and blood clots
yeah maybe there's a link between the
shots and nerve damage yeah maybe maybe
maybe seems like a big L for the science
wouldn't you say because at the time we
were told well look whatever Dr fauci
says whatever the FDA whatever the CDC
says that's the science Dr fauci said
I'm a representative of the science
that's why people don't like me well man
that science just sure seems to be
getting a lot of things wrong right
it does now
what you will hear people who defend the
science say now is well
that's not the real science
they'll say Dr fauci no no that's the
politicized science or the FDA and the
CDC no they that's the corrupted science
but we what we need to do is trust the
science the real science capital S
you'll even hear a lot of conservatives
say this
that's not that was not my argument my
argument from the early days of covid
was not I've got you've got your
scientific data but I've got my
scientific data and my scientific data
are better than your scientific data
that was not my argument my argument in
the early days of covid was I don't
believe your scientific data but even if
those data were true I've got my
political philosophy I've got my
inherited tradition I've got my
anthropology my view of of human nature
and political communities I'll simplify
it I've got my rights okay and I don't
give a damn about your stupid scientific
study that's probably bogus anyway
because there are other modes of
knowledge and there are other things in
our society that we should value beyond
the musings of witch doctors wearing
white lab coats that was always my
argument
and there are I think many conservatives
share that view of things but there were
some conservatives who wanted to play by
the libs rules and and simply have a Tit
for Tat over the science oh you've got
your statistics well I've got my
statistics you've got your study well
I've got my study
oh yeah the problem isn't with the
science the problem is that
true science has never been tried that's
basically the argument that we're
hearing at this point
from the people who really defend this
scientistic worldview
the kind of people who argue against
transgenderism by saying well women just
have two X chromosomes that's what it's
all about no it's it's more than that
women actually are more than their body
parts women actually are more than their
their genome it's not simply because
women women's bodies look a certain way
that that's the reason that women
shouldn't go into the men's bathroom and
men shouldn't go into the women's
bathroom it goes deeper than that
I I'm I'm totally sick of hearing this
line that basically amounts to the true
science has never has never been tried
it reminds me of the of the Communists
and the Socialists and all the other
utopians
if the true science has never been tried
then
then why are we trusting it if it can
never be instantiated in real life then
why are we trusting this my view is that
science is fake I gave a speech on this
at Wisconsin Lutheran not that long ago
and
it my view I know it's somewhat
controversial but it appears to be
shared by one of the most powerful Tech
billionaires on the planet that would be
Peter Thiel
you have to ask some very tough
questions whether uh this this notion of
a stem shortage is actually something of
a fairly big lie that we've been told
where uh that uh that um you know uh one
of one of my my colleagues believes that
uh that uh the stem shortage was uh was
was uh this is sort of a this is a
left-wing conspiracy theory but uh he
believes it was it was concocted by the
Reagan Administration in order to
encourage too many people to go into
these fields and drive down all their
wages
um but um but um
um but even if um even if there's no
sort of a full intentionality along
those lines uh one one uh it's it's sort
of it's an incredible gloss on things
and uh and you know I sometimes wonder
whether the people who are in stem
fields are actually even worse than
often the people in Humanities field I
think the humanities Fields you have a
pretty clear sense that um you will not
be employable based on what you've
studied and so uh you'll scramble really
hard to figure out what you're actually
going to do
um whereas um the people who are in
these stem Fields you know maybe under
the um the illusion that there are
actually well-paying jobs in those
fields I love this clip this clip has
been going viral over the past few days
I mean it's a it's a very good argument
which is that we're all told that you
should major in stem don't major in the
humanities but that might be mistaken
because it's giving you false hope
because at least the people majoring in
Humanities know that they're not going
to get a job based on their degrees the
people in stem believe that they will
but very often the people who are in
stem are are not learning things that
are directly applicable to some job
certainly not in the M part of stem the
the mathematics part of stem the ports
that are not just applied science
engineering and the like things that
should be applicable to trades but even
then if you study some particular type
of engineering if you're if you're just
studying
a preparation for a specific job well
that might become outdated six months
later
or 10 years later you're studying
something that is not going to give you
a an education applicable to lots of
different types of jobs and that that's
been my argument too it's another place
I break with a lot of the kind of modern
conservative talking points which say if
you go to a school if you go to a
college you should not major in
literature or history or philosophy or
anything like that that's for the libs
you should just major in engineering and
in a way I think the opposite is true
I share the concern that the humanities
Fields have been completely destroyed by
the libs and by wokeness and the science
Fields have largely been described by by
them but not entirely
and maybe you shouldn't go to college at
all I'm totally open to those things but
if you're going to study something I
think you should study the liberal arts
I think you should study not the
technical Arts that prepare you for a
job
necessary I mean if you want to go to a
vocational school and you want to go to
trade school and you're you're doing
that with your eyes wide open go for it
but if you if you want to get a liberal
arts education then actually study the
liberal arts the point of which is to
help you make sense of your freedom help
you make sense of your culture help you
make sense of these higher things that
you can then go get some on-the-job
training to apply that to a real life
profession because so much of our modern
political
chaos owes to the fact that people don't
understand anything beyond certain
applied sciences but we don't understand
the bigger questions why are we doing
the things that we're doing how do we
make political decisions what is a human
being what is a human being for and do I
have to listen to Dr fauci and get that
dangerous shot that could potentially
mess up my body
and if I don't have to do that then why
these are the deeper questions that are
not simply going to be answered by the
science
let's take a look at the science on
transgenderism there's a new study out
that knocks down another study
and the other study that the new study
knocks down was considered the gold
standard
in evidence for transiting the kids
there was a a gold standard pile of
evidence
in support of medically transitioning
trans identified children it's called
The Dutch studies and and this was what
all the libs pointed to to say actually
this is why we've got to put little kids
on puberty blockers and why we've got to
put them on hormones and why we
potentially got to chop them up when
they become teenagers because it
alleviates all their pain and it makes
them feel much better and everything's
hunky-dory well there's a new
peer-reviewed paper just published last
week that looked at this gold standard
Dutch study evidence and found it quote
has profound previously unrecognized
problems
and requires quote
urgent attention from the medical
community this is according to the
society for evidence-based gender
medicine which is an international group
of over 100 Clinic clinicians who do not
want to
trans the children
the paper here which uh which is
involves this group that has not only
clinicians but researchers it's called
the myth of reliable research in
pediatric gender medicine okay I'm glad
we've got our studies I'm glad for
people who are persuaded by this stuff
that that we can point to a study now
and say see there's the study believe
that study don't believe that study but
you don't need a study to know that a
little boy is a boy okay if you need a
guy in a lab coat to tell you that a
little boy is not really a little girl
then something has gone wrong in your
education something's a little messed up
in your brain okay this is the result
not of bad
biology not of bad chemistry not of bad
applied sciences this is the result of
bad epistemology by which I mean
this is a result of people not knowing
how we even know things anymore I
referenced a really great book that's
about to come out I just gave a blurb
for it called evangelization and
ideology and so it's on it's on a
completely different topic from what
we're talking about right now but but
the author Matthew petrusic
is a really good way of thinking about
this in the book which is that the
things that we're debating right now are
politics right that's at the center of
the
series of concentric circles get the
politics outside of politics you've got
applied morality your view of Applied
morality is going to affect your view of
politics then outside of that circle is
morality broadly the more kind of
abstract moral principles
outside of that Circle you're going to
have epistemology
how do we how do we know things how do
we deduce things about the moral order
and everything else
outside of epistemology you're going to
have anthropology what is human nature
what are human beings we the people who
are supposedly going to know things
outside of anthropology is ontology what
is being what is what does it mean to be
and then outside of ontology you get
theology which is the question what
fundamentally is reality all about what
underlies all of the other stuff that
we're talking about here and and the
error that we're making errors at every
single step of that that series of
conceptual circles but the the big one
is epistemology
the fact that we think that we can only
know things if we can look at it under a
microscope
and it's it's why we use all of this
ridiculous language now when we talk
about transgenderism in particular we
say well
you know a biological male went into the
girl's bathroom the other day it's I'm
using very scientific language I'm this
is the kind of language that a clinician
and a lab coat might use yes I took my
stethoscope and I found out that this
fella wearing stiletto heels in a dress
with the biggest Adams Apple you ever
saw he's actually a biological male
oh so so he's a guy
well I'm using very technical
scientifically sounding kind of language
he's a biot no he's a guy he's a guy
there's not it's not like there are
different types of male there's a
scientific male there's a spiritual male
there's a psychological man it's just a
guy you're a guy why because because
getting to the anthropology human beings
are body and soul and and those two
things are linked because we're
hylomorphic
so you can't have a female soul and a
male body that's
that's that's bad anthropology
and how do I know that well because I I
can
reason philosophically
because I uh recognize that man is made
in the image and likeness of God because
I can recognize the existence not only
of matter but of form and I can
recognize the soul is a substantial form
of the body none of that requires a
microscope it's because my epistemology
is not limited to this the stupid way of
thinking that we all talk about today
those are much bigger problems you want
to know what what
what transgenderism is all about I've
got a clip for you right here this this
is a clip is just going around of the
new owner of the Miss Universe contest
this is what transgenderism is all about
welcome to the Miss Universe
organization
from now on it's gonna be
ran by women
[Applause]
but are women really around the world to
celebrate the power of feminism
diverse cultures
social inclusion
gender equality
creativity the Force for good and of
course the beauty of humanity
so
do you think you need a study to know
that something is wrong about that that
person is jakafang jakra jujitip
I'm probably mispronouncing that name he
goes by Anne he used to go by Andrew he
is the current owner of Miss Universe
Miss USA and Miss Teen USA
beauty pageant organizations and he is a
fella who has had some surgery to make
him look more like a woman
and and he says that the contest is now
run by women
I don't think he's really fooling
anybody and the clip is going viral
specifically because he's not fooling
anybody he's not fooling the
conservatives he's not fooling the
feminists it's very offensive to to
women I think to say hey ladies yeah us
us gals you know we're here we're
finally running Miss Teen USA and Miss
Universe and all the rest of it isn't
that girl power huh the women are
thinking uh
this is not
I think I'm kind of being had here I
don't this I don't think that the women
are actually running these pageants yet
right right of course not but everybody
looks at that we say okay we know that
something's wrong with that
I I urge people always to to
cultivate a conservative Insight it's
one that Russell Kirk talks about a lot
it's one that Edmund Burke one of the
founders of modern conservatism talked
about a lot
and that is
trust your prejudices
most of the time
not all of the time you can have unjust
prejudices and that that can be a bad
thing
but most of the time your prejudices are
going to be correct because your
prejudices are pre-judgments and
pre-judgments are the way that we have
to operate in the world because for
every decision that we make we make
countless decisions all the time where
we're going to walk what we're going to
wear who we're going to talk to what
we're going to say what we're going to
drink what we're going to sit down and
do what's going to distract our
attention will we answer the phone we
make these decisions all the time and we
don't write 50 Page Long treatises of
perfectly rational explanations as to
why we make those decisions or why we
feel a certain way about certain things
we couldn't do that we wouldn't be able
to operate in the world if we did that
and so we've got to rely on our gut
we've got to rely on our Instinct we've
got to rely on just prejudices which is
to say the inherited wisdom that we have
from our tradition
you might not be able to articulate
precisely why it is wrong that a dude
who's had a bunch of weird surgeries and
is wearing stilettos is prancing around
on stage calling himself a woman and
taking over Miss Universe in the name of
women you might not be able to
articulate in the perfect rational way
why it's wrong for a man to go into a
girl's bathroom I think given enough
time you probably could but you might
not be able to right on the spot that's
okay you still know it's wrong and you
know it's wrong because of something
that Leon Cass the great bioethicist
referred to as the wisdom of repugnance
you know that that's wrong it's okay to
know that you don't need some scientists
to give you permission to know the
things that you already know the
scientists are wrong most of the time
anyway
speaking of the weird trans stuff there
is a young teenager really sad story
California teenager who was exposed to
some naked man at the YMCA while she was
she was getting changed this is Rebecca
Phillips just 17 years old she explained
this disgusting situation during public
comments at the January 11 Santee city
council meeting
my name is Rebecca Phillips and I'm 17
years old I am not a resident of Santee
but I am employed at a local restaurant
The Omelette Factory and I work out
regularly at the Santee YMCA
just two weeks ago after finishing my
shift at my job I went to the gym to
swim laps
as I was showering after my workout I
saw a naked male in the women's locker
room
I immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone
I ran into a bathroom stall to change as
quickly as I could organizing my
thoughts to share with the people at the
front desk when I asked the YMCA
management what their policy was
regarding transgenders they confirmed
that the man that I saw was indeed
allowed to shower wherever he pleased
as long as you are not a red flag on
Megan's Law
the California sex offender registry a
grown male can shower alongside a
teenage girl at your YMCA location here
in Santee
I was made to feel as though I had done
something wrong when I talked to people
at the YMCA
an absurd story obviously this teenage
girl should not be made to shower with
naked dudes because those dudes happen
to have some sexual perversion that
makes them derive pleasure out of
pretending to be a woman and stripping
down in front of little girls obviously
that is the case and she says you know I
was made to feel wrong about my natural
feelings of disgust and fear at seeing
some dude strip down naked in the girls
room I was made to feel wrong like
that's bigoted like that's prejudiced
obviously that's not wrong obviously
she's right
she this girl with her natural
prejudices is right and most of the
scientific establishment today that
pushes this woke PC line of
transgenderism in all their lab coats
with all their microscopes they're
completely wrong like they are wrong a
lot of the time like they were wrong
about what they told us about covid and
the vaccines and and lobotomies and
leaching and so many of the other wacky
scientific theories that have come up
over time
so girl 100 right not her fault at all
now I have a I think a deeper reaction
to this that I haven't heard anyone else
bring up and it's probably going to be
controversial and Media Matters is
probably clipping this out right now but
I don't care because I think actually
the fact that nobody is talking about
this is why conservatives so frequently
lose in the culture
why do women go to the YMCA
it's the YMCA
what's that the young men's Christian
Association
why do women go there now there used to
be
something like the y w c a young women's
associations there are gyms for women
there are all sorts of things for women
why is it now that everything has to be
totally mixed
I'm not I'm not saying it's this girl's
fault why did this girl go to the YMCA I
know she was invited to the YMCA she's
probably a member at the YMCA I'm asking
why does the YMCA admit women and why do
why why does our culture want women to
go to the YMCA why can't there be
separate spaces in in certain fields for
men and for women
well because
increasingly we're told that men and
women are not different they're not
complementary they're interchangeable
and it's not just the libs who believe
that the libs are the ones who pushed it
but many conservatives have accepted
that as the truth
and what conservatives do is we always
just fight the craziest newest symptom
of a cultural error that goes much much
deeper
so what you'll hear conservatives say is
well listen
I don't care about
what weird sex stuff you all do and I
don't care about I don't care about gay
marriage I don't care about feminism I
don't care about this that and the other
thing you everybody can do whatever they
want
and I don't care if a man wants to put
on a dress and get his body chopped up
by a doctor if he's over 18. I don't
care about any of that but don't do it
with the kids
yeah I don't care but listen I don't
care if you go in and read a bunch of
stories in a crazy sexualized outfit
it's part of drag queen's Story Hour to
fifth graders but don't do it to third
graders that was actually the argument
in Florida well in Florida which good on
Florida they went out and they banned
this kind of weird grooming
trans-education stuff
in elementary schools they only did it
from pre-k through the third grade
in fact one of the
jokey ways to refer to the bill was the
wait till eight Bill and then it
starting at nine years old
then you can be exposed to all this kind
of transgender propaganda just don't do
it to the eight-year-olds okay well
maybe to the eight-year-olds but don't
do it to the five-year-olds okay five
well don't trans the two-year-olds and
we just keep retreating
but transgenderism is the natural
consequence of this fundamental error
that men and women are interchangeable
and that's an error that goes back not
just to gay marriage
that's an error that goes back not just
to the gay rights movement of the 1990s
that's an error that goes back at the
very least to feminism
because all of these movements take part
of the same faulty premise feminism says
a woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle men and women are exactly the
same the only difference is that our
bodies look a little bit different and
even then that's not a big deal
okay if that's true then then obviously
you're going to have the normalization
of
homosexual relations if if a man and a
woman is the same thing as a man and a
man the same thing as a woman as a woman
then it's all the same if you're going
to do that then you have to redefine
marriage and if you're going to do that
if a man and a woman are exactly the
same then why the hell can't that guy
shower in in the the locker room with a
17 year old girl
why not men and women are exactly the
same oh okay you're willing to admit
finally that men and women are not
exactly the same well then how far back
are you going to take that
are you going to take that back to
men and women have different roles
within a marriage
that marriage therefore has a special
meaning and that sexual differences at
the heart of that that men and women
have different roles within a political
community and within Society willing to
say that even many conservatives
probably would not want to do that
because it's not just the libs
one problem is conservatives are very
often just fighting for the liberal
position five years ago
and that's why we keep losing now
speaking of marriage and weird sex stuff
there's a headline
this is pretty bad this is pretty bad
it's gone viral
and I I have a take on it this is that
Today's show is going to be called
Michael's unpopular opinions but why not
that's what we're here I'm not here to
Pander to you okay I'm not here to
sugarcoat you and throw you only what
you want to hear I'm here to tell you
the hard truth as I see it so this is a
headline exclusive
Daily Mail husband of Tennessee cop
going wild Megan Hall
stands by his wife and tries to salvage
their marriage after she was fired for
having sordid sex romps with six
colleagues as she shrugs off the Scandal
and says it's time to move on
she's 26.
and her husband is 28.
and
she slept around with a lot of guys so
someone writes to me because I've spoken
on the show about how I don't think
divorce is good and should be avoided
pretty much at all costs uh though in
certain instances if a woman or her
children face the threat of violence say
a separation a physical separation might
be permitted or even even morally
required but divorce per
say is very bad I think
it's a summer writes and says hey
Michael in the case of this article
going around about the woman who
cuckolded her husband six times with his
colleagues uh do you think that's
sufficient grounds for divorce
and the answer the real hard answer
strange as it may sound to our modern
culture
no
no that's not sufficient grounds for
divorce at least at least as far as I
see it
at least as far as the traditional
Christian teaching is the traditional
Christian teaching on divorce which is
still believed by the Catholic church
and many if not most Protestants and
Christians around the world is that
there is no good reason for divorce
basically again it's certain limited
circumstances there could be an argument
for a kind of a separation and yeah I'm
not denying that
but that there is no good reason for a
divorce
and I'm not I'm I'm somewhat surprised
that people are so surprised by this
because this was
standard Christian teaching until
relatively recently
and relatively and when I say relatively
recently by the scope of Christianity I
mean recent the past few recent
centuries
some Protestants have argued that
divorce is good in certain cases or can
be permitted
but
I don't I don't really see why this is
so shocking it's kind of like when when
you bring up abortion
and people say well you oppose abortion
you say yes say well do you you oppose
abortion what about in the case of rape
and incest which is really the same
thing right we're talking about incest
we're talking almost always we're
talking about rape so what about in the
case of rape and you say well that's a
very hard case I agree I recognize
accounts for way less than one percent
of the abortions that happen every
single year but uh my premise is that
human life has value from the very
beginning and it's wrong to kill people
and also killing your baby is not going
to make up for a terrible crime that was
committed against you it's not going to
make you feel better it's probably going
to make you feel worse it's not going to
bring Justice to your rapist at all it's
just going to commit an injustice
against a little baby and so from my
premise the human life has value from
the very beginning I have to conclude
that abortion is not permissible period
so same thing here if you're arguing
that that marriage is the Perpetual
Union of a man and a woman for the good
of the spouses and the sake of the
education and generation of children
then
that then that's that if you if your
premise is that marriage is
indissoluable
meaning you know if you if you find out
that that the marriage was fraudulent in
some way that uh a husband was actually
hiding that he was previously married or
the spouses didn't mean their vows when
they said they're vows or there was some
element of fraud you could have an
investigation that's called annulment
meaning the marriage was Nell from the
first place but if you really believe
that marriage is indissoluble what God
has joined let no man separate then you
just can't support divorce in in recent
centuries some Protestants have pointed
to the so-called acceptive clause in The
Gospel According to Saint Matthew which
says that uh except except for the case
of pornea which is sometimes translated
as adultery or an unchastity or other
things except for the case of that
divorce is no good and they say this
well this is an exception
this is a novel argument from the
perspective of historical Christianity
the line does not appear in the gospels
of Saint Mark and Saint Luke does not
appear in the writing of Saint Paul the
meaning of the word pornea is quite
uh controversial I don't think it means
what people say that it means I don't
find this argument particularly
persuasive but it's these hard cases
that really allow you to see your
premise
do in the case of abortion do you really
believe that life has value from the
very beginning
and that people are people no matter how
small it's wrong to kill people okay
then you've got to stand firm on that
even in the hard cases do you really
believe you conservatives who say we I
support marriage I support Family Values
do you really believe that marriage is
indissoluble
even if look it's a Fallen World we all
make mistakes we've all had tough
situations happen to us I'm not shaming
anybody for being divorced half of
marriages end in divorce but in the
principle of the thing
do you do you really believe that well
if you really believe that
then this
cop who's trying to work it out with his
wife who's
got problems
that cop is doing the right thing
you know Jeremy's razors
is offering a big discount right now 40
percent off all Razer subscriptions why
well I'm glad you asked that one year
ago today
Joe Biden tried to force vaccines on
just about everybody here's what Jeremy
co-ceo and God King of the daily wire
had to say about that
we won't be enforcing Joe Biden's
unconstitutional and tyrannical vaccine
mandate that's it we'll use every tool
at our disposal including legal action
to resist
that's right that's the same Jeremy from
Jeremy's razors who you may remember
from that Viral commercial
oh
did you see any other CEOs out there
publicly suing the government on your
behalf no just Jeremy the best part
about it is that we won
the Biden vaccine mandate is as good as
dead we said do not comply and you did
not comply in fact over a million of you
signed our petition saying as much and
today together we kicked the
government's ass
so are you going to keep buying from
those other guys or from the guy who
sued the government on your behalf and
one for all the ladies out there give
your man something else to smile about
every time he picks up a Jeremy's razor
he will remember just how much you care
trust me if he listens to this show too
he will appreciate you even more will
make it even easier for you switch now
get 40 off on your razer subscriptions
at jeremy'sraisers.com
speaking of
the marital Embrace there's a new statue
in Boston of Martin Luther King
I think I guess
the statue is
getting a lot of play online
because it some have said there are two
theories on what it looks like some have
said that it it looks like it's just I
guess it's just arms interwoven together
some have said that from certain angles
it looks like a man engaged in another
kind of embrace which is not as as
wholesome as the Embrace of two arms
that's one some have said it looks like
a man holding up
part of one's body that is not an arm
and some have said that it looks like a
guy
hoisting up
excrement that I'm trying to clean up
all the jokes that I've seen online
about this very very ugly statue but
apparently according to the artist it is
a statue
commemorating and embrace between Martin
Luther King and his wife Coretta king
and the sculptor Hank Willis Thomas
says that he saw this 1964 photo of MLK
wrapping Coretta up for a hug after
hearing that he'd won the Nobel Peace
Prize and so this modern artist decided
to depict this in a sculpture only with
the arms
and it's really really ugly
why is it ugly most people don't seem to
identify why the sculpture is ugly the
sculpture is ugly because it is
grotesque and the sculpture is grotesque
in precisely the way that modernity is
grotesque
which is that it
it forgets that people are supposed to
have heads and chests
the modern art is depicting people as
just weird limbs disconnected from the
rest of the body disconnected from the
most important parts of the body
the the mind that makes us rational and
the chest which gives us spiritedness
which which represents courage which
represents our beating heart
the lifeblood moving through US
modernity doesn't view men through the
lens of heads and chests C.S Lewis wrote
a very very famous work on men without
chests men who lose their spiritedness
men who lose their Manliness
and the whole culture seems to have lost
its head has completely lost its reason
that's why we let men go into the girls
room and why we listen to what stupid Dr
fauci has to say Okay so
people know intuitively
that Modern Art is ugly and grotesque
and we don't like it and yet we keep
seeing so much more of it why is that
one it's because of the absolute
perversion of the people who happen to
be in power but two it's because we
often fail to give perfectly rational
explanations of why Modern Art is so
ugly
well we all know it's ugly you look at a
at a 14th century Cathedral and you look
at the Embrace this weird melange of
arms kind of scooping together
we know that one is more beautiful than
yet look at the pieta look at the
Embrace tell me which one's more
beautiful
look at
beautiful Gothic buildings look at ugly
modern skyscraper type buildings we know
that the former are more beautiful than
the latter
but we don't trust our own prejudices we
don't trust our own gut
our gut is is Right more often than our
scientists are that is a that is a Roger
Kipling wrote a great great piece on
this great poem The the gods of the copy
book headings
and people wise people throughout all of
human history have understood that
time-tested wisdom the wisdom of the
tradition
is 99 times out of 100 at least going to
be better than whatever newfangled idea
happens to pop into your head this is
why I'm
often defending traditional conservatism
as opposed to different brands of
conservatism like neo-conservatism or
libertarianism which is often lumped in
with conservatism I often go back to
traditional
conservative views with an emphasis on
tradition
not because I think that a practice that
has been done for a long time is the
be-all and end-all and that any old
practice ought to be continued into
perpetuity but just because I trust the
wisdom of the countless generations of
men who came before us more than I trust
the prideful ideas of some over
credentialed undereducated dummy in a
lab coat
speaking of modern artists
Hunter button
breaking news Hunter Biden still not a
great guy not a great guy there is a
story that's that's being reported now
Hunter Biden
is trying to prevent his illegitimate
daughter from using the Biden family
name as her own name
uh the the girl's mother Hunter's baby
mama
uh Ms Roberts just asked the circuit
court judge Holly Meyer for her
daughter's last name to be changed to
Biden why would she want her daughter's
last name changed to Biden because she
says this this would allow her daughter
to quote benefit from carrying the Biden
family name Biden name is now synonymous
with being well educated successful
financially acute and politically
powerful
now some of those things are true I
don't think all of those things are true
well educated I don't know about that
certainly politically powerful certainly
successful
financially clever that's certainly true
Hunter Biden now going to court to try
to stop this
Hunter has denied that he's the father
of this child Hunter has tried not to
pay child support for the child Hunter
and his entire family have refused to
acknowledge the child Joe Biden won't
acknowledge his own granddaughter uh
Hunter then went back to court tried to
lower the child support payments that he
is required to make this Hunter Biden
who's selling his
hideous Modern Art canvases for half a
million dollars a piece and Hunter says
he can't pay the full child support that
he owes to his daughter and now he wants
to prevent her from taking his family
name
and the most Shameless part of Hunter's
latest
slight against his daughter
also happens probably to be the truest
which is that the argument that Hunter
Biden his lawyers are making in court in
court is that the girl should not take
the Biden family name because the Biden
family name is a disgrace
that's the actual argument Hunter's
lawyers are saying that if this little
girl takes the hunter Biden name she's
going to be attacked for it she's going
to be smeared in the press that it's
gonna it's gonna make her life worse
and I don't think that that the argument
that Hunter's lawyers are making is the
actual reason that he's trying to
prevent her from taking the Biden name I
think the bidens are trying to keep her
from using the family name because that
would then if she used the name it would
require the Press
and everybody to acknowledge that she
actually is one of Joe Biden's
grandchildren and the family wants to do
whatever it can
to ignore this girl and neglect this
girl
not acknowledge that she exists Joe
Biden puts up stockings at the White
House for all of his grandchildren he
doesn't include this poor girl
could you imagine you're growing up your
grandfather's the president of the
United States and he refuses to
acknowledge that you even exist
could you imagine how that would make
you feel it's a really terrible thing to
do and and Joe Biden who sometimes has a
reputation it's always a nice guy
everybody likes Joe that's a really
cruel nasty thing to do to your own
little grandchild so I think that's
that's why the Biden family is doing it
but the argument that they're making I
think accidentally happens to be correct
the Biden family name is an absolute
disgrace and they are a representative
of a whole modern liberal culture that
is shallow that is nasty that is that is
corrupt they they are a bye word for
that I agree if I were the girl I might
not want the name either probably want
the perks that go along with it and I'd
like the name to at least Force the
family to acknowledge my own existence
but but Hunter's lawyers accidentally
probably happen to be correct that that
Biden name sure is a disgrace now
today's music Monday which means that
I'm going to have to channel
all of my genius powers of cultural
criticism I'm A hip-hop mogul man you
know me I'm really hip to The Jive on
the cool modern culture so we've got a
song that I will be reacting to over in
member block the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
this is actually our only member block
of the week
which by definition makes it the best
one of the week so our only member block
of the week I will be traveling a bit
this week and it's it's not going to be
possible to do the member block for uh
for every show this week so head on over
become a member right now use code
Knowles kwles dailywire.com Knowles use
code nulls at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign
[Music]